this winter the UK's grid is under
immense pressure at the moment it's
incredibly volatile a war in Ukraine
a squeeze on energy supplies
the solution is gas the National Grid
has warned there could be blackouts if I
can just do a little bit and it helps
that's everything for me
now electricity where it comes from how
it's distributed and what happens when
there isn't enough is on everyone's mind
but we now need to double down on Net
Zero it's a terrible argument unless
you're willing to go back to
pre-industrial days
this is the story of what it takes to
get power to UK homes and of what it
takes
to keep the lights on
[Music]
in the wild beautiful Shetland Islands
change is in the air
this is the site of the Viking onshore
wind farm
eventually there'll be 103 turbines here
enough to power all the homes on these
islands and then some
well Shetland is statistically the
windiest place in the UK If you can't
build wind farms where the best wind
resources in the UK then there's
something wrong
so there's a 260 kilometer cable between
Shetland and caithness in the north of
Scotland Aaron priest has lived here all
his life
and the shift to wind is a chance to
leave the past behind
Shetland has a very very large carbon
footprint as well it's the center of oil
and gas production and our power at the
moment comes from fossil fuels it is the
future for Shetland and it'll provide
great opportunities for future
Generations here
turbine parts arrive at the Port the
shape of shetland's next chapter and all
part of the big business of wind power
the government has ambitious plans to
more than quadruple the UK's wind
capacity in the coming decade and
decarbonize the UK's power generation
completely by 2035.
at a neighboring site already up and
running we climb a turbine to get a
different view of what is to come
earlier this year UK wind power set
records generating over half of the UK's
electricity but the problem is when the
wind stops these turbines stop producing
electricity and because we can't store
renewable energy at the scale necessary
yet something else has to fill the gap
in the kitchen and everything that I can
switch off without it causing a problem
to reset it then I will do this winter
people like Wendy Hall wrapped in her
dressing gown while the boiler is off
are helping to match supply and demand
here we go she is taking part in
something called the demand flexibility
service a National Grid scheme being
used for the first time which pays
people to use less electricity at times
of peak demand how much money have you
managed to save
um well there's a 31p there there is a
94p there and there is a one pound 38
but the real purpose of this is more
serious on very cold very still days it
is a way of averting a worst case
scenario it's about avoiding blackouts
for people who need the electricity I'm
not worried about the money it's not
about that thinking about the war days
they dug for England they made to
amended
um and if just switching the power off
for one hour
is a help to other people then I'm happy
to do it yeah so nothing to hurry
nothing to worry about the whole lack at
the moment that's it
the scheme is the brainchild of the
National Grid's electricity system
operator where they are responsible for
keeping the lights on so when you try
and initialize
the stability you get all of these
errors
lots of them in the control room they
balance the system on a second by second
basis
amid a global energy crisis driven by
the war in Ukraine they need all the
tools they can get
Britain is a modern Rich developed
Nation
why are we asking consumers to turn the
lights off to stop blackouts from
happening it's an insurance policy our
assessment for this winter was that
there were a number of
um sort of risks that could arise and in
some scenarios we could foresee that we
might have more challenging conditions
than we've maybe had in recent years but
in a world of intermittent Renewables
and smarter technology and appliances
the message from the grid is clear
things are going to change for all of us
demand flexibility is going to be a
really important component of our energy
Supply mix Going forwards and it will
grow and grow as something that we all
get used to once we've got electric cars
and we don't have gas boilers anymore
we're going to be using energy very
differently to how we use it today
consumers being able to shift their
demand is likely how we're all going to
operate in the future
but before anyone thinks about the
future there is the crisis this winter
to get through and to do that coal has
become a last line of defense against
blackouts Drax the UK's largest Power
Station Burns wood pellets now but
recently the government requested that
old coal units go on standby in case
more electricity is needed in the coming
months
it is a bit strange to see Cole coming
back onto site having cleared it all off
site
but we're able to hear react to changing
world you know a war a war in Europe
with Ukraine that wasn't predicted that
means that people like us if we you know
we can provide that pack of power then
then that's what we're able to do here
and we're very pleased to be able to do
it
at the Ratcliffe coal-fired power
station near Nottingham they are also
ready to boost Supply our power plants
uh aren't weather dependent and so we
can ramp up and ramp down very quickly
we can respond to changing demand and we
and we play our role helping the
National Grid electricity system
operator to to keep the lights on
but that won't be the case forever
coal is a polluting relic of the
Industrial Revolution and its era is
almost over phased out entirely by the
end of next year so what will fill the
gap
the the role of gas is is really
important and the role of providing
large-scale flexibility will shift and
will be picked up by gas fire generation
as we go as we go forward in future
years
it is a fuel brought into sharp focus by
the war in Ukraine and Vladimir Putin's
throttling of supplies to Europe
the conflict proving how dangerous it
can be to rely on foreign powers for
energy
so far though the UK's supply has coped
flowing from the North Sea or shipped in
on tankers and that's a good thing given
how much depends on it gas is an
absolutely critical part of the UK's
Energy Mix of course a lot of us use it
to heat our homes but last year for
example power stations like this one
provided around 35 of the UK's
electricity
so this is the turbine Hall
Bill Cliff got his first job climbing
pylons in the 1970s now he runs this
plant in Enfield and responds daily to
requests from the grid to help
with the way the system is at the moment
it's incredibly volatile and we fill the
gaps we fill the Peaks and the troughs
because we're available we're reliable
and we're responsive
the British public no the ins and outs
of what it takes to run this place
I don't think so
but in all honesty it's not a problem we
know our role we have a deep sense of
purpose deep sense of meaning in what we
do and we're happy doing that
and the British public can be rest
assured there are people in the power
industry that is working in the
background to keep the lights on today
and to decarbonize tomorrow
but some industry experts are much less
confident the rush to ditch fossil fuels
part of the problem
we're running into a supply crisis in
the middle of this decade we have
legislation in place that requires all
the coal power stations to close by
October 2024. there are also two of our
remaining nuclear power stations
schedules were closed in March 2024 so
we have a situation where
um the winter after next
um all of the spare capacity that we
currently have which is about four
gigawatts is the spare capacity motion
that will have gone there will not be
that spare capacity margin anymore
so we need to replace that and the only
realistic way of doing that is to build
gas power stations now two years isn't
really long enough to do that there are
those who say hydrocarbons caused this
mess this energy security mess the only
way out of of said mess is to get off
fossil fuels faster to accelerate into
Renewables is that a good argument do
you think it's a terrible argument
unless you're willing to go back to
pre-industrial days you know if you want
people to sit and shiver in their houses
in the dark in the winter then great go
for it but I don't think that's
acceptable desks looking at all of those
different variables that can influence
that balance between supply and demand
the CEO of eon Michael Lewis there is no
room for negativity he believes we need
to get off fossil fuels as fast as
possible however difficult that may be
this does require a huge National
investment and a huge National effort
but if you look at what we did after the
second world war we built the central
electricity generating board we
electrified every home we built the
nuclear in history we built a gas
industry it's that kind of effort that
is required and we did all that in 30
years after the war we can do it again
and if we do it again we've got the
prize of Net Zero and a long-term robust
Energy System independent of fossil
fuels independent of international
volatile gas prices
[Music]
the government says that it's now more
important than ever to boost the UK's
homegrown energy Supply highlighting its
energy security strategy and its focus
on Renewables nuclear and North Sea oil
and gas
the lights have stayed on for the moment
but in a changing world nothing is
guaranteed